the dusty plains of southern India for
the venue for one of nature's most
astonishing hunts
it's an unusual face-off in one corner
the Cobra spectacle Cobras can grow up
to more than seven feet in length
their venom attacks the nerves which can
kill a human in as little as 30 minutes
Cobras are normally shy but when
threatened they can become very
aggressive especially when a furry
predator starts sniffing around
in the other quarter the Mongoose at
first glance this curious mammal may not
look like much competition for a cobra
but the Indian grey Mongoose is quite
the predator itself and its
lightning-fast reflexes and thick hide
have enabled it to add snakes like the
Cobra to its list of favored foods the
snake tries to warn the mongoose away
making use of that famous hood and raspy
hiss but the Mongoose is persistent and
on the hunt when the Mongoose moves in
to attack the Cobra strikes and misses
again and again each time the Mongoose
dances just out of reach but when the
mongoose attacks he doesn't miss
snake will be on the menu tonight
Rudyard Kipling would be proud